قالت السويد انها ستجري تعديلات قانونيه
تمنح الشرطه والحكومه صلاحيات لمنع حرق
الكتب المقدسه كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم الخطوات التي
اعلنت السويد انها بصدد اتخاذها ثم
منعكاسات هذه الخطوه على نظره بقيه دول
اوروبا للتضارب بين احترام المقدسات
الدينيه وحريه التعبير ثم كيف يمكن للدول
المسلمه والعربيه الاستفاده من نتائج ضغط
حكوماتها المتزامن على السويد
[موسيقى]
سيكون هناك نقاشات من اجل اجراء اصلاحات
قانونيه من اجل منع اي انتهاكات قد تصل
الى جرائم الكراهيه ليس من الواضح ما الذي
ستقوم به الحكومه قد تكون هذه العمليه
طويله الامدال خطاب نوايا حسنه نضلها كذلك
لكن
القوانين الاوروبيه حينما هناك حتى تتحول
الى قوانين قد تصبح سته اشهر اذا لذلك يجب
ان نتعامل مع هذه
التطورات بحذر وان ننتظر حتى تتحول الى
اجراءات قانونيه قابله للتنفيذ بشكل مباشر
لا نتكلم عن مهاجرين فقط نحن نتكلم عن
مواطنين السويديين من اصحاب الديانه
المسلمه الذين يحسون الان بانهم يتعرضون
ان هناك معاداه الاسلام بان هناك اجراءات
عنصريه وفاشيه وشعبويه في حقهم حاله من
الحمله الدعائيه الحزينه التي يحاول فيها
الاشخاص ان يقوموا
بوضع مجموعات مجتمعيه مختلفه من اجل خلف
صدام بينهم بالتالي علينا ان نتخذ الحذر
اشكاليه كبيره على على على حساب مفهوم
الحريه حريه التعبير لا تعني حريه
الكراهيه وجرائم الكراهيه في حق الاخرين
عدم التصدي لهذه الاجراءات هو خدمه لاجنده
اليمين المتطرف الذي هو في تصاعد في
الدنمارك وفي السويد وفي بقيه الدول
الاوروبيه تم تصوير السوفيتي على انها دول
معاديه للاسلام او لديها كراهيه للاسلام
اعتقدوا ان هنالك هذا امر غير صحيح هذه
نسبه صغيره فقط في المجتمع ليس هنالك
اسلام فوبيا في السويد هذا المهاجر
العراقي الذي قام بحرق المصحف الكريم
المصحف الشريف لو قام هذا الرجل بحرق
العلم السويدي سيرحل في اليوم نفسه لا احد
يتكلم عن حريه التعبير حين ذاك حينما تحرق
العلم السويدي حينما تحرق الدستور السويدي
لا توجد حريه انذاك هذه جريمه كراهيه
واعتداء على مقدسات وعلى ثوابت الامه
السويديه فاريد ان ارى ادله عما يسمى
بالاسلام لان السويت ترحب باللاجئين من
دول
يكون فيه الاسلام هو الدين الاساسي لنا
اذكر فقط الاجراءات الظالمه التي تعرضت
لها المئات ان لم اقل الالاف من العائلات
اللاجئين المسلمين الذين هم في الذين هم
في السويد والذين تحولوا ابنائهم الى
تجاره مع المصلحه الاجتماعيه وهناك
تحقيقات وهناك شهادات كبيره لصحافه
الاستقصائيه التي ابانت على ان هناك اراده
لتهديد المسلمين الذين يعيشون في السويد
هذه حمله دعائيه بدات منذ سنوات عديده
ويقوم بها ارهابيون يهدفون الى نشر الذعر
والكراهيه في المجتمع السويدي مجرد اني
وصفت ان تصرف الحكومه السويديه تجاه
العائلات المسلمه بانه الغرض منه هو دفع
عائله مسلمه تفكر في اللجوء الى السويد ان
تخاف على اولادها وصف للرجل بالارهابي هذا
الرجل مجرد مجرد نقد الحكومه السويديه
بالنسبه له ارهاب واولاء امارس حريه تعبير
بينما في الوقت ذاته يعتبر حرق القران
الكريم هو مجرد حريه تفكير وحريه التعبير
هذا هو الكيل بامكانيه طب انتم تخلقون
انشقاقا وخلافات في المجتمع وهي مروعه اذا
ما اخذنا بنظر اعتبار التاثير على الناس
الذين يعيشون في السويد وكيف ان من
المنطقي على الحكومه ان تقوم بذلك في
الوقت نفس الوقت نحن نرحب باللاجئين
والمهاجرين من بلاد الاسلام لماذا نقوم
بخطف الاطفال حريه تفكير وحريه تعبير
حينما تتكلم لكن حينما تعتدي على مسجد
حينما تعتدي على مصلي على مؤمن حينما تعدد
تحرق القران الكريم انت لا تعبر عن بحريه
عن فكرك انت هنا تعتدي على ح الاخرين
الضيف الزميلي الذي يتحدث اعتقد انه
يستخدم حمله دعائيه
ناجحه
نتحدث عن الاحتجاجات الرمزيه هي لا تستهدف
الاشخاص لكنها تستهدف الافكار والافكار
مرتبطه بحريه التعبير لو قام احد الناس
بحرق العلم
المثليين سوف ماذا سيعتبر هذا هل يعتبر
حريه في السويد لم يعتبر حريه بل سيعتبر
جريمه كراهيه
يقحمون حقوق المثليين باي حوار ويقولون ان
هنالك معايير مزدوجه لماذا يتحدث دائما
هنالك حديث عن حقوق المثليين عندما يكون
هنالك جدل حول الحريه
[موسيقى]
خطاب النوايا الحسنه او الاجراءات
المحتمله من طرف الحكومه الدنماركيه او
الحكومه السويديه هي بالاساس رد فعل على
تحركات الدبلوماسيه وخصوصا اجتماع الوزراء
خارجيه مجلس التعاون الاسلامي راينا هجوما
على السفاره السويديه في العراق هذا في
حقيقه الامر ادى الى
دفعه بالحكومه السويديه ان لا تستمع الى
المطالب التي قدمها قاده
الدين والدول الغربيه هي تفكر بمنطق
المصلحه فاذا رات ان مصلحتها مهدده
ستتراجع عن هذه القرارات حينما يعرفون ان
مصالح السويد الخارجيه الاقتصاديه خصوصا
هي مهدده وكذلك خلق توترات مع دول قد
تقارب عددها المئه في العالم التهديد بسحب
التمثيليات الدبلوماسيه او قطع والغاء
العقود التجاريه والاقتصاديه مع هذه الدول
وكذا مع الابقاء على قنوات الحوار مع
الدبلوماسيه مع هذه الدول هاته الوسائل
الحقيقيه واللازمه من اجل حفظ مصالح هذه
الدول الاسلاميه